hi my name is Dan Kelly I'm an
infectious disease specialist at the
University of California San Francisco
I've been working in Sierra Leone for
the past eight years my last trip prior
to this one who had been in June I was
there for two weeks at that point I
didn't think this bullet outbreak would
be where it is now life was as it always
has been in Freetown & Co know his
business as usual but when i returned to
sierra leone about 3-4 weeks ago wow I
felt like I was entering a war zone
isolation words that were overwhelmed in
Freetown and hospitals that were nearly
empty because the community was so
scared during their loved ones it felt
like a death trap I mean who would want
to go to a place where your insurance
isn't gonna cover you in America and
your government's not gonna protect you
so basically I was told when I made a
phone call to the US Embassy that if I
get sick they'll help coordinate a plane
but I'll have to pay for it so I felt
really alone disheartened I can only
imagine how people who don't have a
community support network and know what
they're doing in the country would feel
well I think everyone is a bit scared
about Ebola and it is a deadly disease
it's not just Americans but it's also
Sierra Leoneans for sidelining
themselves not responding the crisis
which was confirmed when I got there on
the ground and just saw a complete
vacuum of staffing of isolation centers
at capacity treatment centers I just
hope the people really reach inside
themselves and respond now to Sierra
Leone Liberia Guinea and this a bull
outbreak as they did in the haiti
earthquake want more download the aj+
mobile app and join the conversation
available in your app store name